your CEO or senior leader in a company
what should you be doing with your
LinkedIn account the ability to use
LinkedIn both as a marketing channel
like a Facebook or a Google
a personal brand an individual to speak
on subject matter is the big opportunity
for most people on this call they just
have to speak about things they actually
believe in and want to talk about but
they have to make it as if they are on
CNBC and are an anchor or they write for
the New York Times or the Wall Street
Journal not as an executive there's not
a soul on Earth that wants to hear your
press release that your people wrote for
you as a LinkedIn post on the flip side
if you may pretend that you just retired
and you got a full-time job at CNBC or
the Wall Street Journal and you wrote
about macro issues that touch on your
business you can find yourself in very
fruitful grounds for business
development